as a dietitian these are the foods I
never keep in the house okay so you
probably were expecting me to say chips
and cookies and ice cream but since
healing my relationship with food I've
really found that I've been able to keep
these Foods in the house and largely
forget about them so what do I never buy
pretty much just things that my family
and I don't like number one kale chips
like why eat your kale and have your
chips like I always find that they're
just so dry and I kind of feel like I'm
gonna choke when I eat them number two
low calorie ice cream like hell to the
no no no honestly it just tastes like
air and sadness to me I go with the OG
and three energy drinks those are like a
big No-No for me because I have anxiety
and insomnia I don't need like 200 plus
milligrams of caffeine in one go so I'm
gonna stick with my usual latte if you
guys are working on your relationship
with food I know it can feel really hard
to keep some of these trigger foods in
your house but hit that follow if you
want to learn how